vorbereitungen für eine protestaktion
sie wollen der bundesregierung später
ihre meinung geigen
dabei moritz und tabea fürchten eine
doppelte belastung durch die krone
ausgaben dass sie die schulden zahlen
müssen und dass zukunftsinvestitionen
aufgeschoben werden dass die großen
unternehmen gerettet worden und
milliarden bekommen haben und wenigkeit
den klimaschutz zusagen geflossen ist
eigentlich kein geld da stellt sich
natürlich dass schon die frage warum
gehen die gelder dahin und nicht zum
beispiel in vier nachhaltiger bereiche
oder in den sozialen sektor beide sind
anfang 20 studierenden dresden und
erfurt und sie sind teil des jugendrats
der generationen stiftung die gruppe
kämpft für bessere chancen der jungen
generation heute werden sie vor dem
bundeswirtschaftsministerium
demonstrieren die gruppe von aktivisten
sorgte schon mehrfach für aufsehen zum
beispiel als sie 2018 symbolisch den
generationenvertrag kündigte im
vergangenen jahr forderten sie vor dem
kanzleramt einen generationen
rettungsschirm ihre botschaft die korona
milliardenschaden der jungen generation
ich sehe das ist der regierung wichtiger
ist die existenz der konzerne zu retten
als die der menschen liebe frau merkel
warum wird meine generation immer wieder
übergangen liebe oder auch stolz wo ist
die rettungsschirm für das klima sie
fordern wenn schon schulden dann
wenigstens nachhaltig investieren bei
der kundgebung wird habe er zum ersten
mal eine rede halten letzte generalprobe
politische entscheidungen wie das
konjunkturpaket im zuge der korona
pandemie haben allerdings auf gezeigt
wie sehr die politik nach
wirtschaftsinteressen handelt und die
wenig die junge generation bzw unsere
meinung im politischen diskurs gehör
findet glaubt es kann so richtig gut
gleich zu machen ok
peter altmaier es bei demonstrationen
auch schon mal raus gekommen hat mit den
demonstrierenden gesprochen und das wäre
natürlich so dass top outcome wenn er
sich den wirklich stellt und mit uns
diskutiert bei der kundgebung vor dem
wirtschaftsministerium werden wir die
beiden wieder treffen doch ist ihre
sorge auf den schulden sitzen zu bleiben
berechtigt ist der schuldenberg wirklich
so hoch
an der berliner humboldt-universität
sind wir mit marcel fratzscher
verabredet er ist präsident des
deutschen instituts für
wirtschaftsforschung und professor für
volkswirtschaft er rechnet uns vor wie
umfangreich die hilfspakete sind
die gesamtkosten der chorakademie für
den start im jahr 2020 und 21
zusammengenommen liegt ungefähr bei 500
milliarden euro die größten zusätzlichen
staatlichen schulden seit dem zweiten
weltkrieg
[Musik]
der ökonom teilt die hilfen in vier
kategorien ein hilfen für unternehmen
machen den größten teil aus
daneben gelder für menschen für länder
und kommunen sowie internationale
unterstützung für staatsunternehmen
gestützt das unternehmen nicht pleite
gehen mussten bestand augenmenschen
direkt auch geholfen aber ein
kritikpunkt eine schwäche ist dass der
staat vor allem sich darauf fokussiert
hat dieses geld auszugeben um den status
quo zu erhalten
und ganz wenig dieses geld ist nur
wirklich in zukunftsinvestitionen
gegangen ist in klimaschutz in die
digitale transformation ein besseres
bildungssystem aus sicht der
bundesregierung war die bazooka ein
voller erfolg zwei millionen
arbeitsplätze und 400.000 unternehmen
wurden ihr zufolge gerettet
[Musik]
ohne staatliche hilfen hätte auch dieses
kino wohl nicht überlebt nach sieben
harten monaten geht es für laura weber
endlich wieder los sie ist erleichtert
[Musik]
die vergangenen monate hat familien
unternehmerinnen laura weber anträge
ausgefüllt jetzt geht es endlich wieder
darum kinokarten zu verkaufen an diesem
tag hofft sie auf zumindest 2000
zuschauer früher kamen um die 10.000 pro
tag ein guter start ist enorm wichtig
daran hängen mehrere hundert jobs gegen
nachmittag ein erster blick auf die
zuschauerzahlen
der umsatz ist durch die pandemie im
vergangenen jahr massiv eingebrochen
von mehr als 20 millionen euro auf vier
millionen
um die umsatzeinbußen zu dämpfen hat das
kino knapp vier millionen euro
staatshilfen bekommen
[Musik]
außerdem hat ihr die kurzarbeit geholfen
nur deshalb ist der großteil der
mitarbeiter noch da sie gilt als
wichtigste maßnahme des starts um in
krisenzeiten jobs zu sichern während der
pandemie kam der staat für einen teil
der lohnkosten drauf im april 2020 etwa
waren sechs millionen beschäftigte in
kurzarbeit ein jahr später waren es nur
noch halb so viele die arbeitslosenquote
stieg in diesem zeitraum nur wenig auch
das kino wurde so vorerst gerettet laura
weber hofft dass sie von den hilfen
nicht zurückzahlen muss zu beginn der
krise wurde oftmals direkt der
höchstbetrag ausgezahlt nun wird noch
mal genau geprüft ob möglicherweise zu
viel bezahlt wurde könnten
könnte halt dazu führen dass man keine
investitionen in die zukunft machen und
kann wie zum beispiel brauchen ja
irgendwann neue projektoren oder
besitzer regelmäßig tauschen und wenn
man natürlich geld abzwacken muss um die
hilfen zurückzuzahlen für monate wo wir
keinerlei einnahmen hatten es ist
natürlich schwierig wie läuft der start
an diesem tag auf 2000 besucher hatte
laura weber gehofft knapp 1000 kommen am
ende sie bleibt trotzdem optimistisch
hilfen für kleine und mittlere
unternehmen hier kommt nur das zurück in
die staatskasse was zu viel ausgezahlt
wurde noch gar nicht in den 500
milliarden gesamtkosten eingerechnet
milliarden an krediten und beteiligungen
durch die der staat großkonzerne
absichern der tourismuskonzern tui etwa
hat kredite von 4,3 milliarden euro
bekommen 9 milliarden euro wurden der
lufthansa in aussicht gestellt wie viel
davon zurückkommt unklar durch hohe
zinsen könnte der staat hier am ende
sogar gewinnen machen doch überleben die
konzerne nicht muss der staat in die
bresche springen
michael harbach hat angst vor einer
sozialen spaltung des landes er ist
millionär der kunstsammler verkauft
bilder von künstlern in not und
unterstützt sie damit finanziell
der 70 jährige hat früher als
wirtschaftsberater sehr viel geld
gemacht von seinem vermögen will er
etwas abgeben
[Musik]
kroner lässt die staatsschulden wachsen
wer soll das ganze am ende bezahlen
klare antwort die reichen sind mal
wieder dran wir reichen ich zähle mich
dazu weil man den schwachen nicht mehr
zumuten kann noch mehr zu zahlen
zusammen mit anderen millionärin
unterstützt er eine initiative zur
wiedereinführung der vermögenssteuer
viel zu lange habe der staat reiche wie
ihn bevorzugt
die steuern sind gesenkt wurden von
53 prozent auf 42 prozent
die vermögenssteuer ist ausgesetzt
worden und es gibt eine klare
umverteilung von unten nach oben so dass
die reichen in den letzten jahren immer
reicher geworden sind horbach spricht
sich auch für eine vermögensabgabe aus
wie sie die linkspartei fordert das
reichste prozent der deutschen soll je
nach höhe des vermögens 10 bis 30
prozent abgeben die ersten zwei
millionen das privatvermögen sphären von
der abgabe nicht betroffen bei
betriebsvermögen sind es fünf millionen
euro zu zahlen wäre die abgabe nach und
nach über zwanzig jahre lang geschätzte
einnahmen für den staat 310 milliarden
euro zur erinnerung die korona krise
dürfte etwa 500 milliarden kosten das
macht für die reichen eine zusätzliche
steuerbelastung pro jahr von 0,1 bis 1,5
prozent und ich bin mir sicher dass
dadurch keine investitionen verhindert
wird also da sollen wir bitte keiner
kommen und theater machen sie haben sich
das selber hatten sicherlich
durchgerechnet wie viel müssten sie nach
diesem modell jährlich abgeben also das
durften so um die 50.000 euro pro jahr
sagen was haben sie da zum beispiel die
sozialen frieden wenn arm und reich wenn
das immer mehr auseinander
driftet dann haben wir irgendwann die
probleme die es ja jetzt in südamerika
gibt dh die reichen leben in goldenen
käfigen ich möchte aber nach wie vor
ohne bedenken mit meinem fahrrad durch
die kölner südstadt fahren
[Musik]
vermögensabgabe für reiche auch er wäre
davon betroffen
david solo beschäftigt 350 mitarbeiter
seine firma ist spezialisiert auf
elektroinstallationen
das geld liege nicht auf dem konto
sondern stecke in vermögenswerten wie
maschinen und geräten ist es nicht nur
gerecht dass diejenigen die mehr haben
was abgeben das ist genau mein humor
also erstens weiß ich nicht wie reicht
die reichen sind die meinen sie werden
wieder dran ich weiß auch nicht was die
für geschäftsmodelle haben
ganz klassisch gesagt ich halte das für
eine vor allem ist kunz debatte und ich
halte das auch für das völlig falsche
signal das richtige signal sein die
unternehmer sind dran jetzt auch wieder
mit dem was sie haben aus eigener kraft
den laden wieder ans laufen zu bringen
so das geht aber nur wenn man den
unternehmen eben auch ihre ihre mittel
lässt er findet extra steuern für reiche
ungerecht und vertritt damit auch die
interessen vieler familien unternehmer
es ist das alte beispiel wenn zwei leute
arbeiten und das gleiche geld verdienen
und der eine sagt ich verballert das für
meine freizeit oder oder verkauf ist
sprichwörtlich in der kneipe ja und der
andere sagt ich gehe lieber zur
bausparkasse ist zwar langweilig aber
ist auf die zukunft gerichtet dann kann
ich doch nicht hinter hingehen und sagen
na ja du hast besser gewirtschaftet als
der andere dafür wirst du noch bestraft
das versteht kein mensch was würde es
bedeuten wenn so eine vermögensabgabe
kommen würde die unternehmer die hier
vor ort sind haben schlichtweg weniger
geld zum investieren das heißt wir
treten auf die wachstumsbremse in dem
augenblick und die ganz großen summen
die wandern wahrscheinlich ab von den
500 milliarden krisenhilfe wird wohl nur
wenig zurück fließen
wer soll die korona rechnung also
bezahlen
in der politischen debatte wird viel
über steuern und abgaben für reiche
diskutiert cdu/csu fdp und fdp sind
gegen eine beteiligung von vermögenden
die linkspartei und die grünen dafür wie
steht finanzminister und spd
kanzlerkandidat olaf scholz zu einer
vermögenssteuer
solidarität und fairness sind nach der
krise dringend nötig auch in
großbritannien gibt es eine
vermögensbesteuerung von unternehmen und
deshalb wäre es schon in ordnung wenn in
deutschland diese einnahme wieder zur
verfügung steht für in ordnung aber
einsetzen dafür würden sie sich jetzt
nicht aktiv ich halte das für richtig
deshalb bin ich ganz froh dass die
sozialdemokratische partei dass sich zum
programm gemacht hat das heißt wenn sie
kanzler wären dann würde der
vermögenssteuer kommen das habe ich so
angekündigt warum soll also das ist klar
wir werden das machen und ab welchem
vermögen gilt das dann
und wird das im einzelnen festlegen
müssen aber es ist ganz klar dass
diejenigen die über ein sehr großes
vermögen verfügen da ein beitrag leisten
müssen und auch können es geht nicht um
diejenigen die ein privates
einfamilienhaus zu erben haben
zur schuldenbewältigung baut scholz fiel
auf die selbstheilungskräfte der
wirtschaft auf wachstum in der nacht
pandemie zeit würden die unternehmen
wieder kräftig steuern sagen
es kann man zuverlässig als fakt
annehmen dass das wachstum seit die
kosten trägt ich bin sicher dass das
wachstum uns in die lage versetzen wird
die kosten dieser krise zu tragen
woher nehmen sie die fakten
das war letztes mal so es war fast wie
bei so und die meisten seriösen
volkswirtschaftlichen theorien halten
das ist nicht nur konkret und auch
generell als maßnahme der
krisenbekämpfung für richtig der
internationale währungsfonds hat der
guard gesagt deutschland hat es am
besten gemacht und glaubt es stimmt
olaf scholz hat sich mit seinem
schuldenkurs gegenüber der union
durchgesetzt ein fehler sagt eckhardt
rehberg er ist der haushaltspolitische
sprecher der unions-fraktion und mahnt
seit vielen jahren zur sparsamkeit ich
glaube dass und auf scholz mit dazu
beigetragen hat
dass sich da auch die meinung breit
gemacht hat schulden machen wäre kein
problem es sei genug geld vorhanden los
das sind die schulden der bürgerinnen
und bürger und ich hätte mir gewünscht
dass er da etwas zurückhaltender wie es
aus meiner sicht
aufgabe und funktion des
bundesfinanzministers gerecht geworden
wäre
rehberg fordert so schnell wie möglich
zurück zur schuldenbremse denn
grundsätzlich gilt die haushalte von
bund und ländern sollen ohne einnahmen
aus krediten auskommen
in der korona krise wurde diese regel
ausgesetzt
warum ist ihnen das so wichtig dass sie
sagen wir müssen zurück der schulden der
stadt sagt ich mache schulden ohne
grenzen
dann fragt sich der bürger was ist
eigentlich los ich glaube wir tun gut
daran ab dem jahr 2023 die schuldenregel
wieder einzuhalten dass man beim
bundeshaushalt zukünftig wieder maß und
mitte ein held an der stelle und
deswegen habe ich solche begriffe wie
bei super wurms immer für falsch
gehalten wenn ich jetzt den haushalt
ausgleichen will wenn ich schulden
tilgen muss habe ich eigentlich nur zwei
möglichkeiten ich kann die einnahmen
erhöhen oder die ausgaben senken wo
würden sie ansetzen ich bin davon
überzeugt dass mit wirtschaftlichem
wachstum und mit einer seriösen soliden
haushaltspolitik ja auch die
schuldenbremse eingehalten werden kann
die mitglieder vom jugendrat fürchten
dass die korona schulden den weg für
zukunftsinvestitionen verbauen und
machen politik und lobbyismus dafür
verantwortlich
gleich soll die kundgebung vor dem
wirtschaftsministerium losgehen
studentin tabea wird das erste mal bei
einer kundgebung eine rede halten
tabea nebenbei noch mitglied der grünen
jugend fordert mit dem jugendrat strenge
soziale und ökologische bedingungen bei
den hilfen für großkonzerne
ob sie die politik diesmal mit ihren
forderungen erreichen die politik
spricht über schulden die gemacht werden
müssen und weil investitionen die
getätigt werden müssen für die menschen
so sagt die politik dennoch wurden
milliarden in sterbende industrie in
umweltschädliche industrie investiert
wie zum beispiel intuit oder lufthansa
und der muss die schulden am ende
bezahlen wir die junge generation
wie kann so etwas sein
nach der rede erleichterung
einige menschen stehen geblieben das war
cool ich glaube wir haben ein gutes
zeichen gesetzt und ich glaube wir waren
so laut dass er auch im ministerium
gehört worden die bundesregierung direkt
konfrontieren konnten sie nicht
wir fragen nach beim
bundesfinanzminister und spd
kanzlerkandidaten die jungen leute mit
denen wir gesprochen haben die sagen auf
den schulden werden nachher wir sitzen
bleiben was sagen sie denn wenn wir das
schaffen dass es mit dem
wirtschaftlichen wachstum hinhaut dann
wird es ganz klar die linken das nicht
die junge generation die kosten der
krisenbewältigung zahlen muss sondern
dass sie profitieren wird was sagt der
minister zum vorwurf dass hilfen für
großkonzerne nicht an ökologische
bedingungen geknüpft wurden niemand kann
realistischerweise jemals sich in einer
krise vorstellen dass man wenn man
millionen unternehmen rettet für jedes
einzelne unternehmer an den befindet er
sich eine meinung dazu bildet was
konkret in diesem unternehmen zu
geschehen hat das ist eine nicht ganz
realistische vorstellung im übrigen auch
eine die irgendwo funktioniert aber bei
lufthansa werden sicher 14 beamte mit
beschäftigt haben was man dafür
bedingungen stellen könnte klimaschutz
bedingungen zum beispiel oder ich bin
ganz sicher dass das was wir dort zu
machen hatten erst mal dafür war dafür
sorge zu tragen dass die unternehmen
gerettet werden können und das finde ich
ist auch genau der auftrag den wir
hatten und das was man
realistischerweise erreichen konnte
die schulden der korona krise durch wen
wie und wann sollen sie beglichen werden
und woher kommt frisches geld für
zukunftsaufgaben
im wahlkampf setzen manche allein auf
wachstum
andere wollen ausgaben kürzen oder
steuern erhöhen und reiche extra zur
kasse bitten fest steht irgendjemand
wird die rechnung zahlen müssen ohne
klare konzepte droht die krise nach der
krise
[Musik]